let me give you this this is why I think
the beginning of the incel movement and
the black pill movement was born out of
pick a Artistry the origin if you trace
it back using internet history of the
incel blackpill uh ideology was a I
think it's a subreddit or a website
called Pua hate pickup artist hate and
what it was was a group of men who had
been through the pipeline of pickup
Artistry yeah and come out the other
side with a very jaded and even more
jaded view of the world even more jaded
yes and I'll tell you why so what
happens if a guy learns old school mid2
norts pickup
Artistry is you realize that there is a
particular set of actions a script that
you can run which makes it more likely
that a woman is going to go to bed with
you right right right right but what you
realize when you do that as you learn
how to neag and do Kino escalation and
tell them that story about the
fight outside or whatever your script is
that you're running you then begin to
see just how far away that person is
from the person that you actually show
up as right who you are and this
extravagant Persona that you need to
convolute into existence in order to get
this woman into bed makes you feel worse
even F the gap between where you are and
what you have to do in order to achieve
the thing that you want now what you
don't realize is that there are a
million other ways that you could become
sufficiently Charming to get this person
to like you this is by actually doing it
for example this is just one that
happens to be robust and easy enough to
write down in a book and easy enough for
most guys form of scripted
psychopathy so what a psychopath does is
feain competence right so most
psychopaths are very emotionally stable
and so one of
the early St stage markers for
competence is self-possession and
calmness and so if you're not an anxious
person you've got an edge on that
already and most psychopaths are very
high in emotional stability and so they
look confident because confident people
tend not to be that nervous like if
you're doing something you're expert at
well you're not nervous because you know
how to do it okay so the lack of
nervousness is a hint to competence well
you can feain that you can feain
competence
you can feain confidence that's what the
pickup artists teach now I would say
there's even some utility in what they
do right because if you're dependent and
bitter and resentful and charmless and
self
destructive and nervous and socially
unskilled the probability that you're
going to be successful with women is
very very low okay so you should be
other than who you are now if you start
putting on this Persona then you could
think about that as a new suit of
clothes and you could learn through that
how to fill in the gaps take it until
you make it absolutely absolutely but if
you take on that without doing the
effort necessary to integrate that in a
genuine way then all that's happening is
that you're you're being rewarded for
being fake yeah right and that's part of
the problem with that too is that you're
practicing learning how to manipulate
people in a Psychopathic way and if you
practice that of course you're going to
become jaded like there's nothing more
jaded than a psychopath I mean that's
that's the ultimate extreme of jadedness
and if you practice
manipulating especially if the women
happen to be reasonably good women if
you practice manipulating them and
you're successful then you're learning
to be one you're learning to be one
horrible person now you know as you're
completely useless unproductive and
undesirable former self you weren't
exactly Stellar to begin with but
substituting psychopathy for that was
sort of like substituting cynicism for
naivity now that's a complex problem I
mean part of the reason that people like
Andrew Tate are so attractive to young
guys is because they do put up
that
confident that false confidence Tate's a
complicated guy cuz it's not all false
you know real people are complicated the
way that like villains in in comic books
aren't Tate's a fighter it's clearly the
case that he's got a certain degree of
physical bravery that's real all
right there's an element of what he says
that's very attractive to bed bedroom
basement dwelling losers because he's at
least there out in the world you know
taking the blows and he's got a fast car
and he's flashy and he's attractive to
women but a lot of what he's done
especially with women doesn't just
border into the psychopathic it crosses
the line and that's not a good model
it's not an optimal model for people who
are trying to progress but it's a
strange thing because just as cism is an
improvement over naivity right the
capacity to be dark is an improvement
over the lack of ability to be dark at
all and so Tate is attractive in the way
that the shadow beckons to people who
are undeveloped right because it does
it's like you're you're neurotic and
you're dependent and you're repressed
because you're immature and harmless
well one way out of that is to stop
being harmless and one of the things you
can say about Tate is that he's not
harmless right well that's that's a it's
a virtue now it's a virtue that has to
be bracketed it's like cynicism is a
virtue compared to naivity but it's not
it's not virtuous in and of itself it's
a step on the way and so maybe you can
learn how to Fain confidence and you can
learn how that works and maybe that's an
improvement I had a guy in my clinical
practice who got involved with the
pickup artist community and he told me
taught me a lot about it and one of the
exercises that their initiates had to do
was to go out and ask 50 women for their
phone number in one day and that's a
great exercise you know and I'm not
exposure therapy approach anxiety
absolutely absolutely getting over your
fear of rejection right and 50 times
they'll do that because you're going to
get rejected the vast majority of times
Well likely 50 times although generally
that wasn't people's experience you know
if if they were even vaguely skilled
they'd at least get a false phone number
out of the deal but then they could they
learned that the rejection wasn't as
catastrophic as they thought but more
importantly they learned that they could
continue moving forward in the face of
rejection so the thing that it makes me
think about there is intellect ual
humility and how tightly people hold on
to their beliefs that if you believe
that you are always going to be right
that there is nothing to learn outside
of you and that any kind of admission
that you might be wrong is tant amount
to destruction it does exactly the same
thing you need to and it goes back to uh
asking stupid questions being prepared
to ask the stupid questions and look not
like the most informed person in the
room but also importantly nowhere near
the most stupid person in the room
because you're the one that's asking the
question the stupidest person in the
room is the person who doesn't know and
won't ask or even worse who doesn't know
and won't ask and acts like they know ah
yeah that's not good at all yeah there's
a from your see that's part of that idea
that you should love your enemy so you
might say well why should you do that
well your enemy is going to be your
harshest
critic now it's possible that if you
have a very good enemy that he will show
you flaws in your character that you
didn't know were there and so that's a
it's a very
it's a very strange way of looking at
the world to think that you should
welcome an attack you should it and this
is but this is
right yeah I'm saying that with all due
caution let's say the most the more
vicious the
attack the more of your potential hidden
flaws might be revealed have you found
that to be true oh definitely but I've
also found that
the attacks force you to contend with it
to to see if it's there right to to test
it I suppose the attacks that have come
after me that have been most successful
they they're almost always journalists
and they're usually British female
journalists but not always we produce a
nation of hard-hitting journalists yeah
well in faith in journalists is the
lowest in the UK and anywhere in the
western world and I can see why you know
but there's some Advantage there's some
real advantage to facing someone it's a
Pharisee problem in in the
gospels Christ was always contending
with these Pharisees and what the
Pharisees were always trying to do was
to lay a verbal trap for him so is a
Pharisee a person Pharisee was a was a
Jewish sect okay and the Pharisees were
very legalistic in their interpretation
of Mosaic law and so they were sort of
they were hypocritical the way they're
portrayed in the gospel SS they're
hypocritical by the book moralists and
part of what and most of their morality
was for show they like to pray in public
they like to be seen being holy at least
that's the criticisms that are levied
against them and what they're always
trying to do in the gospel accounts is
to lay a verbal trap for Christ so that
they can expose him as a heretic and
kill him right so every single thing
they say is a snare of some sort and
there's lots of journalists like that
Nelly Bulls who wrote an article about
me for the New York Times which was a
very devastating article in many ways
and
very Serpentine and and
subtle she three years
later she wrote another article about
what it was like to work for the New
York Times when she was working there
and the tricks that the journalists
played including her and she said that
the game was to devastate someone else's
reputation in the attempt to boost yours
right so you could think about it as a
game of comparative moral standing so
the journalist's trick is to trick you
into saying something that will end your
career essentially their social status
stands on the shoulders of yours AB
absolutely absolutely and so now the the
advantage to being in a situation like
that is that you have to step if you
step extremely carefully
and you're fortunate then you evade the
traps and then the interview tilts hard
in your favor yeah and so the most the
interviews that have done me the most
good in the long run were the two
interviews that were most hostile one
by channels 4 Griffin Kathy Kathy Newman
Kathy Newman Kathy Griffin and Kathy
Kathy at least had a sense of humor
another one by Helen Lewis who had no
sense of humor at all doesn't seem to
have learned anything at all in the
interim but I think that I think that
one has 80 million views now twice as
many as the Kathy Newman interview like
it just keeps racking up views and it
was because Helen
Lewis she has like 50 tricks or 100
tricks Kathy had like four you know and
they were pretty blunt and she had a
sense of humor about them but Helen
Lewis she was just all tricks and lots
of them and smart you know and it's
quite something to talk to someone who's
quite smart and quite educated but all
tricks we'll get back to talking to
Jordan in one minute but first I need to
tell you about element I've used element
every single morning for over three
years now it is the way I start every
single day it tastes fantastic it
optimizes my hydration it helps to
regulate my appetite and it improves my
brain health element contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium pottassium and magnesium best of
all they've got a brand new chocolate
caramel flavor which you can have hot
hot element I hear you say what sort of
hydration blasphemy is this but no it
tastes fantastic and on cold mornings
it's perfect there is a no BS no
questions asked refund policy so you can
buy it and try it completely risk-free
and if you do not like it for any reason
they will give you your money back and
you don't even need to return the Box
I've used this every single morning for
as long as I can remember and that
orange flavor is phenomenal plus that
chocolate caramel is available right now
if you go to the link in the show notes
below or head to drink LM nt.com slod
wisdom for a free sample pack of all
eight flavors with your first box that's
drink LM nt.com
/od wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Jordan you will love the over 3our long
podcast episode which is available right
here go
on give it a tap